Let's go to our caller to the two from the
two one four area code.
Who's calling today from two one four.
Hey David, this is Anthony.
Is this me?
Yes it is.
Hi David.
Thanks for taking my call.
I'm a longtime listener.
Been listening since 2014 when I started college
and I've been a huge fan ever since.
So I'm an actor from Dallas.
I'm on a film set right now actually, uh,
just to have some downtime.
So I thought I'd call into your show
any, uh, is it a production of anything we
would, we would know or,
um, I'm awfully sorry.
I actually can't get into specifics about
what it's, it's sort of a secret project,
so I can't, I can't go into,
well please don't.
Please don't.
No, no.
Yeah, yeah.
But, but anyway, um, so I'm really involved
in the film world and I'm, uh, uh, I'm aware
that currently in preproduction there's, I
don't know if you've heard about it, there's
a mini series that's an adaptation of James
Colome's book a higher loyalty or you're aware
of it?
No, I did not.
I don't know
who's playing me in it.
Oh, I don't know.
Probably Tom cruise or something.
I would say I would go my, if you haven't
listened, if you have any say shoot for either
Joseph Gordon Levitt for me, uh, or, or the
guy that played mr shoe and glee.
Okay.
I'll, I'll look into both of those.
But, uh, unfortunately I have really no say
on it whatsoever.
I'm not involved in that in any, you were
talking early on your show about how you were
wondering about how it's possible to portray
Trump Trump in a way that isn't parody.
You know, it isn't a comical because he's
so ridiculous and salt rage.
Great.
Just how do you play Trump in a straightforward
way, right.
And so the accurate play portraying from his
name Brendan Greeson on this, you know that
actor, he's playing comp and Jeff Daniels
is playing comi.
So, um, I was on a live chat with the young
Turks and I asked John [inaudible] about what
he thought of it and he said he's just afraid
that they're going to present Cohlmia some
sort of heroic martyr.
That's going to be the point of it.
Especially because it's an adaptation of his
book.
How do you, how do you hope that the miniseries
will portray either comi or Trump or how,
what is your hope for how it's going to portray
event?
Well, with comi, I think he should not be
glorified, but he should be listened.
There was something comi was fired.
He was the victim of Trump initially and that
doesn't make him heroic or not heroic.
It doesn't make the actions taken up until
that time, good or bad in any way.
He then decided instead of disappearing, he
would be in the public and he would say things
and do things and whatever.
And you can say that that has some degree
of risk associated with it.
But I think it would be a mistake to glorify
him in some kind of deity.
Like way as far as Trump goes, here's the
problem.
I think there's two options with how you portray
Trump.
If you play Trump in a, in a fictionalization
true to what Trump has done, it's going to
seem like a parody because it's so insane.
The alternative would be that you turn Trump
into a dark villain.
But that won't ring true because Trump is
not an evil genius in that sense.
And that would also not be accurate.
So that's a real tough a, that's a real tough
acting job, quite frankly.
Yeah, exactly.
It's going to be probably a career making
move.
My Mr. Good grief and that, that's something
that, you know, as an actor you try to, um,
you try to find things in your character that,
uh, people can relate to and feeling sympathy
for.
I was watching an interview with the actor
will rough tar who portrayed Lee Harvey Oswald
and killing Kennedy and he was talking about
how he was trying to make Oswald a sympathetic
character and that's not an easy thing to
do.
Um, but he wanted to some degree have you
feel sympathy for the guy you with without,
you know, without, you know, condoning his
actions of course.
Or like thinking like, Oh that like I'm on
his side.
Not, no, not at all.
It's just you have to, you know, give the
audience an understanding of where this characters
coming from and their decision.
Sure.
And it will be quite a job doing that with
Trump.
Yeah, it's a, it's a hake Herculean task and
I've got to run.
But I appreciate the phone call and I hope
to hear from you again.
That does it for today.
Sorry I wasn't able to get to everyone.
I rarely am, but we will take calls again.